that's another thing like police
officers that twenty percent of time
that should be spent training that
includes like how are you getting in
shape are you in shape you want to be in
shape if you're a cop oh my god you know
you see these you see these uh some of
these videos of police officers
and you're thinking wait a second how is
this person gonna gonna stop anybody
that's remotely athletic we did a
podcast on the uvalde situation and it's
just yeah it's terrible what else needs
to happen in america to realize that we
need more training and by the way the
fact that people didn't respond and and
and acted in a cowardly manner is also
part of training if you have a culture
and i used to see this with seal
platoons if you had a culture that like
you had some of these seal platoons
coming through and they were like ready
to take on the world and you throw some
scenario at them they were going on the
attack and that's a culture that that
happens we'd rather have you make a bad
decision and do something than not make
a decision at all yeah
the worst decision is no decision so yes